general motors revient au québec 20 ans
après avoir fermé son usine de
boisbriand dans les laurentides le
constructeur automobile américain et son
partenaire sud coréen posco chemical
vont investir 500 millions de dollars à
bécancour dans le centre du québec pour
construire une usine de cathodes
composante essentielle à la fabrication
de batteries création de 200 emplois la
semaine passée le géant chimique
allemand basse a annoncé un
investissement également des concours
pour une usine de fabrication de
matériaux pour des cathodes et pour
recycler des batteries avec nous ce soir
françois philippe champagne ministre de
l'innovation des sciences de l'industrie
bonsoir bonsoir monsieur millions pour
parler de cette annonce pour parler
d'autres sujets également mais on va
commencer avec cette annonce le
gouvernement du canada et le
gouvernement du québec vont soutenir
tout est fait de quelle façon ben on est
toujours partenaire vous savez moi je le
disais ce matin à l'annonce les grands
projets qu'on a faits soit dans
l'hérault spatiale soit dans la
biofabrication maintenant soit dans
l'automobile on est toujours partenaire
avec le gouvernement du québec mais
aussi je le dis pour les téléspectateurs
les gouvernements ont un rôle à jouer
dans l'équation parce que vous savez
vous en conviendrez on est en
compétition avec beaucoup de
juridictions parce que c'est des joueurs
mondiaux 1 moi je suis juste un coup de
circuit pour le québec pour le canada
mais encore plus intéressant c'est que
l'on s'intègre de façon permanente dans
la chaîne d'approvisionnement de
l'automobile en amérique du nord parce
que cette usine ne s'est pas pour le
marché canadien mais c'est pour le
marché nord-américain de gm qu'on
connaît comme vous dites il y avait 20
ans et vous affichez comme on fait
financièrement comme écouter on est en
discussions avec eux sa voix ressemble
aux mêmes paramètres qu'on à faire parce
que vous savez en même temps on a
beaucoup d'usinés du site d'automobile
du côté de l'ontario donc les paramètres
sont déjà bien établie les diffusions ce
qu'on appelle des prêts pardonnable
c'est à dire on prête de l'argent piano
parti qui devient subventions nous c'est
suivant conditionnelle alors québec
tarde de près par donna bruce est
souvent des contributions qu'on appelle
avec conditions des conditions par
exemple sur la recherche et
développement en condition sur l'emploi
mais pourquoi on a besoin de faire ça gm
fait 10 milliards de profits en 2021
pourquoi les gouvernements doivent
soutenir le développement du véhicule
électrique puis sa filière avec une
entreprise aussi riche que general
motors
c'est la nature de la compétition dans
laquelle on vit parce que vous savez
vous en parliez le géant des asf
allemands pouvaient aller partout moi
j'ai parlé au pdg qui est en allemagne
vous savez ils viennent chez nous mais
il aurait pu aller du côté des états
unis il ya plusieurs états américains
qui leur offraient des avantages
comparatifs intéressant mais ce qui fait
qu'ils sont venus chez nous c'est la
proximité moi je serai à proximité des
ressources proximité des marchés marché
nord-américain proximité des usines
d'assemblage et il ya toujours un rôle
dans l'équation pour les gouvernements
parce qu on est en compétition avec la
france avec l'allemagne avec le royaume
uni et je vous dirais que la tue
habituellement on est assez compétitive
c'est le message que moi j'en vois au
constructeur on est compétitif mais
c'est le talent c'est les ressources la
proximité qui fait la différence vous
avez dit sur twitter dans les derniers
jours que vous aviez parlé à bombardier
à magna international que vous avez
parlé à d'autres entreprises canadiennes
tailleur notamment pour leur demander
quoi pour leur demander de partir de
russie de sortir de russie de suspendre
leur activité aurait coûté un effort
quand on fait tous un effort parce qu'il
faut faire une pression maximale pour
isoler le régime de vladimir poutine
économiquement politiquement
diplomatiquement ces entreprises avaient
déjà fait les bons choix en vous savez
moi je leur ai parlé en les incitant
tendance est la bonne chose même ce
matin j'ai changé avec monsieur bouchard
de couche tard qui eux aussi ont annoncé
des mesures est ce que c'est votre
intervention qui fait que couche-tard
finalement m'a décidé d'annoncer la tuer
je les encourage disons mais je
prétendre est pas ça monsieur bouchard
avait déjà pris la décision et plusieurs
avaient déjà pris la décision mais je
pense que ça crée un effet
d'entraînement et plus tard cette
semaine vous allez voir on va lancer une
mobilisation nationale comme on l'avait
fait pour le coc vite 19 dans lequel on
avait demandé à l'industrie canadienne
de se mobiliser grandvaux demande l
industrie canine de se mobiliser pour
l'ukraine c'est à dire pour maintenant
aider avec les besoins de médias mais on
pense aussi à la reconstruction à on a
vu des images de dévastation comme on
n'en avait pas vu depuis 1945
éventuellement éventuellement évidemment
vous avez dit quoi monsieur bouchard de
coster mais d'abord je veux les
féliciter pour son leadership jeu les
remercier d'avoir pris cette mesure là
parce qu'ils ont je comprend des
opérations du côté de l'europe de l'est
selon lui ce qui m'expliquait c'est par
exemple du côté de la pologne si j'ai
bien compris il avait parce qu'ils ont
des stations service avec on les connaît
ils exigent beaucoup d'employés
l'abandon qu'ils aidaient d'une certaine
façon avec les stations-service fournir
des denrées pour aider les je veux pas
les appeler des réfugiés parce que ils
ont pas choisi de quitter l'ukraine en
tout cas les les les déplacements de
masse convoi de gens pour essayer
d'aider et c'est le genre de chose qu'on
veut voir le canal de gauche nous aura
offert par exemple les manteaux d'hiver
pour pouvoir aider des gens alors on
essaie de mobiliser avec la croix rouge
canadienne pour amener ces denrées là
sur place le plus rapidement possible et
parlant de la guerre en craignant un
effet inflationniste quand même c'est
incroyable dans le prix de l'énergie
dans le prix de l'essence l'alberta a
annoncé aujourd'hui qu'elle suspend sa
taxe sur les carburants est ce que le
gouvernement fédéral va faire la même
chose avec l'inflation sur le prix de
l'essence qui touchent directement le
portefeuille des ménages est
particulièrement les ménages les plus
modestes mais on l'avait lui-même avant
la guerre en ukraine 1 on est tous très
occupés avec les questions
d'abordabilité parce qu'on avait vu même
avant cette crise doit qui avait une
hausse des prix à plusieurs niveaux
nous ce qu'on ne fais moi ce que j'ai
fait depuis déjà la semaine dernière
parce qu'on avait anticipé qu'avec une
invasion comme celle là il y aura une
pression sur les prix par exemple du gaz
de l'essence des denrées comme le blé
parce que j'ai demandé j'essaye du
bureau de la concurrence du canada
d'enquêté c'est à dire d'avoir une
cellule spécifique pour voir s qui
aurait pas d enjeu de collusion des
hors-jeu de pratiques déloyales
allez-vous baisser les taxes sur
l'essence pour l'instant j'ai vu une
annonce de monsieur kenny on regarde
toujours ce qu'on peut faire pour aider
les citoyens vous avez vu que dans le
prochain budget c'est sûr que la
ministre des finances regarde toutes les
mesures on avait commencé avec le
logement on a vu par exemple les ventes
des garderies à l'échelle nationale
toute mesure en plus de la politique
monétaire par la banque du canada qu'on
peut prendre pour aider les citoyens
aussi comme je vous dis avant même la
guerre on avait vu ça on l'avait vu dans
plusieurs prix alors c'est sûr que vous
lever un ticket sa salle une pression
inflationniste
donc on va regarder ce qu'on peut faire
pour aider les gens mais c'est sûr que
c'est quelque chose que qui nous
préoccupe parce qu'on voit ça dans le
quotidien la semaine dernière vous avez
laissé entendre que le transaction
rogers shaw fait pas votre affaire je
pense j'ai été clair vous avez été clair
donc est ce que ça veut dire que la
transaction n'aura pas lieu ce que j'ai
dit j'ai fait correct mais couleurs
parce que je pense que les gens
s'attendaient justement à avoir une
réponse du gouvernement fédéral mon
ministère est une des trois agences qui
doit décider moi ce que j'ai envoyé un
message clair en disant que ce que ch
proposé jusqu'au vote juste proposer
plutôt sale à l'encontre des politiques
établies par le gouvernement c'est à
dire on veut avoir des prix plus
abordable au niveau des salaires plus de
compétitions plus d'innovation alors moi
je voulais envoyer un message clair et
je pense qu'il était entendu parce que
et donc ils vont retourner à la table à
dessin ben ils ont pas le choix parce
que sans l'accord de mon ministère ils
peuvent parler de l'avant alors moi je
voulais leur envoyer un message clair
donc soit une non définitif non parce
qu'ils ont là il l'opportunité en vertu
du processus qui est établie l'ont
toujours l'opportunité de revenir mais
je pense qu'il était dans l'intérêt de
national dans l'intérêt des
consommateurs
d'envoyer un message clair et je pense
que ça permet aux gens d'aller refaire
leurs devoirs en disant écoutez le
ministre parle et vous savez à quoi vous
en tenir maintenant merci monsieur
champagne d'avoir été avec nous merci
monsieur fillon
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici r d